sometimes you just have to make videos
that are super weird and don't have a
concrete plan in an effort to kind of
mix things up a little bit and kind of
make video that's a little more abstract
doesn't really follow any particular
rules or structure just enjoy the
process of making it rather than
analyzing the piece we're on to vapes
this one right here is just going to be
this and these two straps right here and
they're going to kind of wrap around a
typical vape God vape pen then for this
next one it's actually a little bit more
complicated when it's all put together
there's gonna be a tube coming out right
here and then going into the battery
part of it and it's going to have the
juice in there so it's gonna look really
kind of weird gonna hit hard it's kind
of chuck the vapor hopefully Jake
doesn't yell at me don't yell at me
it's been three days since I've started
working on this we are very very very
very very very very close to being done
this is kind of where we're at right now
with the big vape it's a bit jank here
and there but I think it looks pretty
funny Sam was like hey while you're at
the hardware store can you find anything
to make like a second fate just a little
bit smaller so I came up with this thing
it's just so out there like there's just
the two with the baked juice in it like
combining that one on top makes you
stack up here oh my god babe complete
I'm rolling whenever you're ready
I think we got a video right there
another listing the bet thing it looks
hilarious that's how everyone's gonna
vape in the video is just wheeling we're
gonna start with the moment where
everyone just like ghost nicotine free
they do so yeah I'm not trying to make a
pro smoking ad the goal of the days to
come out of it with an up footage to
edit a video and ideally the footage
will be good or funny one of the two
that doesn't need to be good as long as
it's funny and it doesn't need to be
funny as long as this weird hopefully
it's enough footage to make a video
whether it's good bad weird or whatever
be very sure what you put in this soy
sauce sense of syrup maple syrup
almost made me spill my date rollin and
three two one action
ah
you were so red I was like is this the
cameras saturation it's actually pretty
hard to vape it in NL while doing a oh
so bad not a master vapor this is my
Sansa a team member at corridor digital
why the crazy ideas like this one I've
never actually baked it before I've
never taken a pole on a baby really yeah
yeah hold on I got me you know it's
pretty good it tastes like strawberry
air there's no nicotine in this I'm
thankfully not gonna get hooked on one
of the most addictive drugs none mankind
those oh so you're walking in like you
know I'm here to save the world what's
up I'm bringing my powers to the table
how about you what do you bring in to
the table take your fake babe you're
like boom do you exhale it out from the
vape thing is the vaporizing you have to
put like maximum energy levels into into
inhaling and exhaling right now let's
get so wide when we do it hahaha you you
turn into a different person
why whoa
honestly you're moving at such a
consistent speed that you almost
wouldn't attract that I'm gonna do it
again I'm going to shoot wider so we
have more to track because I'm shooting
at 6k we can crop in afterwards do big
sweeping with motion with your arms
pretty nice that was great so we're
gonna get a wide shot of everyone good
work alright I'm going to come down
there and get another one last shot and
we're good
good job super weird right now it's
feeling a little slow because everything
slow-motion you say then you can either
decide to worry about it or not or hey
about it and it's life is a lot easier
when you're not wearing here's the thing
I'm not gonna worry about it I'm gonna
work on it and then we'll come to the
end and I'll be halfway done like we got
uploaded tomorrow you know what I'll
just I'll let it be your problem though
I'll work as hard as I can
and call good we're all this together so
first it's important to notice that
there were a couple big breakthroughs
for us as a company on this video one is
that we got fumefx 4 which is an updated
version of fume effects that we've used
in the past the other thing is that we
got octane version 3 on top of a whole
list of upgrades it is now able to do
volumetric rendering and by that it's
able to do smoke rendering fume effects
is a smoke simulator
octane is a light simulator using the
old rendering system you would have to
like turn off features because otherwise
you would take far too long to render
now octane on the other hand renders
maximum full realistic unbiased quality
all at once immediately but it starts as
a very like fuzzy noisy image and that's
because each pixel although correct is
off by a little bit and so over time all
the pixels are adjusting until they're
perfectly right and that just takes a
lot of time that's another cool thing
about octane is that you can take
whatever time you have and render your
entire sequence within that time you can
take a shot and make it so that it only
takes 10 seconds to render or 10 minutes
the 10 minute one wall waste little
better but the light interaction itself
will still be
they're in the low-quality version ok so
super quick rundown of the actual FEMA
FEX simulation pipeline here you start
with your volume you add some emitters
and emitter is something that just emits
smoke so for the purpose of this I've
got four different emitters each coming
from our heads and they're shooting
smoke down into the center between us
we've got to find the right settings to
kind of mimic your scenes outside it's a
little bit windier so I added some
turbulence so that you get a little bit
more wisp enos to the smoke you can
change the buoyancy of the smoke the
temperature going in how fast stuff
Rises how fast stuff dissipates
eventually you get to a point where like
alright I'm kind of happy with the way
this is looking
I'm going to try a high quality
simulation you crank up the resolution
you guys want a special Ren pro tip for
fume effects here's what I do
simulate at a reasonably high res but
not mega high res then you take that and
you apply what's called wavelet
turbulence you end up with high
resolution looking smoke but you have
low resolution motion and here's the
thing about the Internet no one's gonna
notice that your motion is not high
quality now after doing wavelet
turbulence you have a very very high
resolution file and it's also extremely
big and from there you do what's called
post-processing shrimps all of the fat
out of it it's like oh this voxel
doesn't have any good information in it
delete oh there's not really anything
here except for a bunch of these
channels delete you rake all the excess
fat off of your simulation you end up
with a much smaller file size and that
is what I bring into octane and render
in summary do your simulation subdivided
to make it really high resolution post
process which takes away all the fat and
now you're left with a really
streamlined high quality simulation that
you throw into octane and it renders it
really well the shots we have left are
not easy shots that's our issue which we
can we can probably get all those shots
simulated in the next day and a half but
rendering will be an issue we do have
two octane licenses so I can get two
renders going all night tonight and
another two renders all night tomorrow
night and maybe a render during the day
as soon as I get this done I'm gonna get
it started rendering over on that so I
can move on yeah at this point it's just
a race to the finish trying to get the
rest of the shots done
I just finished the second last shot
it's Friday
1:30 p.m. Bren is finishing the last
shot that means we're gonna be done with
the video once these are done rendering
nine hours 12 hours eight hours is
average just like what / render
depending on - I have at this one can
you make my skimmer guy maybe a
three-and-a-half-hour marker
specifically three and half hours yeah
cool we're not going to do sound design
for this video because right now the
song we're using is very dense very
intense I did edit the piece to kind of
just fit with the track a little more
like a music video than a narrative
piece
basically like stranger things but with
vaping yeah let's do I'm a little upset
about how good team man
SoDo great work dude and so good if you
guys been following us on Instagram or
Facebook heck have you been watching
these videos all year you're probably
familiar with a very big secret project
that we've been working on good news and
the very next video on this channel
we're going to be releasing a teaser for
that project make sure you have all your
notifications turned on so that when we
release it you are immediately notified
you do not want to miss it
this is the largest project we've ever
worked on and we're incredibly excited
to share it with you guys